what is happening there reject nation we're
gonna watch stranger things four by five today
i want to say a special thank you to all who
have joined our patreon page for this series
full-length watch-alongs are you single with
the time code for this show over there for
super sexy rejects along with a bunch of
other shows that we cover at the same tier
reaction highlights exclusives for some of them
included also if you can't do that leave a like
that'd be kind of you we'd appreciate it
please subscribe what also subscribe and hit
that notification bell to get notified when the
rest of the stranger things reactions come out
and then boys at prepper thank you so much for
helping us get through this week means a lot
breaking bad eleven
thoughts and prayers my guy nina nia
bruce nina who's nina okay okay okay
this is the number number hey right
here wait the number hey look at me
yeah we should get off the road
my guy all right get off the road
dead isn't he this is the worst man you could have
gotten into yeah man the least naked speakers man
i said i'm a [__] they always destroy everything
when they search but wouldn't that make it harder
to find things ah i know she was just here and if
you want to live you're gonna tell me where she is
i mean it didn't seem like the odds were
good he was gonna live did you get some rest
a little good have a feeling you're gonna need
it i really don't want him to die but it just
seems that way he is the warmest presence on this
show right now and that alone makes me paranoid
ruth ruth he was coming back
oh 12 hours ago they got caught
[__] this is like some freaking area
51 [__] area 11. okay here we go
how'd you afford all this aren't you unemployed
and i mean before your government salary couldn't
have been that great yeah you'll have to forgive
the staring you're a bit of a celebrity down here
i am oh yeah they hate it angela too never
would cheer when you hit her with that escape
we call her nina
what is it if we told you it would
ruin the surprise no way present
no hello
perhaps in our time apart you may have even
grown to hate me oh no all i've ever wanted to do
is to help you you still come across freaking
evil man yeah let us work together again you and i
got him oh
why don't you go back inside
play nice to the doctor
no don't have creepy guards the more
you move the more this is going to hurt
god damn it this is not how i wanted things to
begin but everything's going to be all right
you're home now that scar it's all
the devagarga left him with he knows
he's got a cool guy's car
now yeah wow what an opener
this show's so cool that makes me question whether
or not i want paul ryser delivered now now yeah
die paul ryan hey horribly the first thing
eleven does when she gets her powers back cancel
i trusted you paul reiser
specifically you paul reiser yes
ah [__] nimrod antal what i tell you
american no run now is going to be much pain
the [__] looks like the
dark knight rises doesn't it
it's a great camera quality i have
expect to hear the chanting just
look at that crazy yeah and the snow is
always reflecting particles of the upside down
yeah right literally yeah the negative image
of that we both knew the risks both of us
are today and we lost
joyce i'm not choice
it's like a prison break thriller man yeah hi this
is not american airlines it's going to get bit
what an shopping
i'm gonna need a food delivery like really soon
unless you want me going out into the world
no no no i don't do what an [__] you know you're
welcome here anytime totally you're like family
really absolutely i want pops to get out of
the action because for all we're worth okay
i just couldn't sleep people kept
blasting music in my ears for some reason
i don't know if something was different he seemed
surprised almost like he didn't want me there
maybe you infiltrated his mind he invaded your
mind right is it that big of a leap to suggest
you somehow wound up in his like freddy krueger's
boiler room ha ha fine i'll call call that freddy
crew is this a window yeah stained glass with
roses yeah see i'm not so terrible after all
yeah well it helps that i've seen it
before that generic window would say
i've seen it before many times in many places
it's pieces of a house not just any house
you guys are so good at arts and crafts
seriously yeah first the maze now this
oh my god did they shave
her head no gi jane oh what
that is so messed up
way to traumatize her guys
yeah jesus what did you expect
is she in like a traumatic memory look
who finally decided to join us someone's
a sleepyhead this morning where am i i guess
you're still not quite awake huh am i in hawkins
well well look who finally decided to join us
what someone's a sleepyhead this
morning is this like a young brenner
oh man
well wow
we shouldn't have just thrown her in
there like this she's gonna drown in there
no she is going to swim you are the jk
simmons from whiplash in the show man
that made you good what do you want got results
what do you want you're one of the best in the
world thanks to me this is so messed up this is
so messed up oh burying the cop himself just relax
okay why do you just go to the van and do your
thing purple pawn tree delight hey that would
just make me more paranoid yeah that's his pen
what unknown hero agent the numbers on the pen
hey man i'm using that what are
you doing oh yeah what is it
it's the number he got his digits man
oh [__] yeah that's what they do here
you sick russians place your bets now
oh crap that's what you do when you get
a monster on your hands yeah man these
days they broadcast them on the dark
web my wife diane she wanted a baby
sarah it wasn't an easy death she
suffered i knew the risk but i um
i hid them
you were right what you said last night i knew
the risks breaking out of here but i did it anyway
a minute i sent for joyce and then i
sent four i sentence her to death nah man
everyone i love i hurt see i was wrong this
whole time i wasn't cursed i am the curse
speaking of use that
you're right about one thing
we are going to die in here
i don't want enzo to die actually okay i can't
get over how beautiful the show looks man i know
love the snow but i know chrissy's in heaven now
but i also know she's frustrated that the
monster that did this to her is still out there
excuse me guys i want to go check out this clock
really fast so weird over there the hellfire club
they're hiding eddie maybe we should bring
all this to the cubs the cops would think
chris is a drug dealer what if they cursed
us or some [__] patrick thinks he's cursed
let's take a break to bully this guy you
should have reefer rick's house to this
what he's eddie supplier he's supposed to be in
prison but someone spotted him back in this house
it's probably nothing i don't know no that's
good [__] it daddy yeah damn it ah [__]
maxis max is like the beverly yeah yeah totally
getting like knee bolt house losers club vibes
from it stephen king wherever we get those do
you need to be told everything you're not a child
don't leave it i just want to leave the
backpack you don't leave anything anywhere
you all see that right yeah
is this what you saw ah
i heard you we're just always partners okay what
you have a problem with that it'd just be nice to
you know i don't know mix it up a bit so what i'm
hoarding is that oh no it's cool seeing that shot
coming to life like what were they staring
at in that photo yeah the stranger things
you can't yeah what
oh my god you could use the peanut butter
cream and slip through the cuffs yes
pour the glass and cut the rope absolutely even
more effective i take him who flies this plane all
right so don't knock him out just get his gun and
make him turn us around eddie's gun just like that
huh is black not the highest color you're a liar
i've never fought in a real world scenario oh no
a great mix of the score well look
who finally decided to join us
oh she's getting mad she's gonna figure this out
the recording says 9479
break the mirror
confront the past and break me whoa wicked oh
oh my god that's eerie yeah oh that's so eerie
look who finally decided to
join us someone's a stupid smart
i'm sorry
wow training starts any minute now this is okay
hey there's nothing to be nervous
about that is so creepy yes
this is an expensive show yep feared
fascinating ah it's really fascinating listen
to this does that remind you of anything
war games huh hmm we're calling a computer
okay i don't know if nina's a
computer like joshua or owen's
lab but unknown cure agent man he
gave us access to it for a reason
music i just need a hat the only hacker
that i know lives in utah oh my god
turn around yes it's time oh
even better they've upgraded the suits
the smoking saucepan it's him he doesn't you
there it's eddie you remember me right hey uh
anyone's there i really think i might
be in a bit of trouble here okay
wheeler anybody oh i hope vacna kills
that one guy so they can see yeah
what the hell
oh stephen steve
what's wrong this is a spider what dater is just
i guess we should get back to the investigation
the obvious things are not what people
observe or down up sir or sherlock holmes
best boy steve harrington best boy
eleven
versus chapter two no stranger things
yeah for days it's a great
effect of the it's well chosen
i'll make it move waste of time
god no wonder she killed all you kids
just bullies every step of her life
this reminds me of the cell good call
wow what a crazy shot swim faster
okay that's enough pour out no or else
oh no you are fragile cargo you can still pray not
if i break you first my fingers are like arrows
my arms like iron get to it but turn this
plane around and i will spay your life
he used the scarf
oh my god jesus joyce
oh god damn this fight's getting
a lot crazier than i expected
fingers are like arrows yeah my arms like iron
oh no now learn to fly at the plane
what are you doing
wow oh bad
that was really expensive that
that did look very expensive
i got him
oh i got him
i had him whoa
oh i think he's moving he's
moving he's moving cool creative
i lost him
maybe max leading isn't the brightest
idea crank that music up guys
what if he's leading us into a trap guys guys
dude i was about to say what's happening
with eddie dustin please are you there
if someone witnesses him die
that could really save them
oh buddy
oh my [__] god oh god damn they're fast
yeah they're going to college on a squid
mix dollar skip that's a cerebral room
he's 100 here
oh no
oh good this is just what they needed oh no
oh jesus christ
air get some air for christ's sake
it's okay it would take time to adjust
these hot head shots man
nah you can escape this time come on come on
you can just feel it coming oh i was like let's go
god i love this season remarkable no
he does know how to bring it out i said stay away
oh no is this still part of the
tank thingy you didn't think
it would be that easy deformation did you
oh you're gonna make her choose
daughter
unfortunately tasha'll get her powers back
sucks but that's i know like let's go
one scene longer i know what's going on
i feel like there's like another one here yeah oh
this is a great season i love this season so far
yeah this is spectacular papa can you hear me
that's the 11th song when she needs a song
this season oh my gosh what a [__] superhero
way to bring back a villain i know like
unfortunately he's the only one who can help
yeah such a superhero thing hey and i mean that's
this episode we've been watching a lot that was
this episode when he came back right oh in the
present day brenner yeah yeah that wasn't the last
episode was this one i think it was this one the
thing about binge tv i mean it does yes it does
it can write i mean and i don't even think that's
bad entirely i mean yeah for for discussing the
confines of a singular episode yes but i feel
like the binge format is designed to just make
you think of it like one long story but yeah
i think this is the one where it confirmed
that it is the present day he is still
here yeah yeah yeah they're on the road
guy dies yeah um yeah what a what a brilliant way
to do that again this show just loves dealing with
drama yeah so much so just rip all those woods
back open everyone's just haunted by their past
and it's like the upside down constantly reflects
um some semblance of of uh traumatic wounds yes
whatever's ailing these people is alive and
personified somewhere in the upside down
even down down to the creation or at least
the the awareness of not victor creole the uh
beckham
velcro uh back now you know just this whole
manifestation where he lives is such a place of
one man's i don't know why there is where he's
choosing to lay camp or if not chosen a lake
camp for some reason that's just the grounds in
which he must reside but that also is a place for
you know that resembles another man's trauma like
everyone's just so this whole thing is just a big
traumatic thing and then hopper lamenting about
all the the pains he's had to endure that's i
i don't recall ever getting like a clear story
of you know having to please his dad and going
off to war and all that like we explored sarah in
season one a lot and that's obviously bled through
with uh his relationship with eleven but we
haven't uh i don't think we got that much past
history so it's just it's cool it's cool how
they're doing this you know with brenda coming
back you're like guys still you don't trust
him but he is the one to get the goddamn job
done yeah the perfect like eerie 80s sci-fi doctor
where you're like not everything is good and right
with you but unfortunately you're the expert
yeah you're the only one who yeah begrudgingly
he represents that sinister line of science where
it's like this is the cost for the advances you
want i don't know what to tell you and to
have eleven shoes at the end it was great
mm-hmm really great yeah going back to him like
she like she knows now yeah that in order for
her to get activated and to come to her fullest
potential i have to accept this yeah yeah oh
boy it's great that's great yeah yeah unfortunate
because you know like i want her to have one scene
with paul reiser where she sees that paul ryser
really does care still yeah he's the one who's
always he's the only leading pull around no what
are you doing dude this is not the right way to
do this like he needs to see that he's not a dick
not total dick you know yeah yeah and i mean you
know i i really love the way that they did the
back and forth of that and the way that they
really put you in the shoes of her distrust the
whole time and i thought that was a good reversal
with paul reiser because he is up until that point
such a warm sweater he's the one person who shows
up and you're like i i think i feel a little
more comforted because of what you're saying
and then here it's like even he is not a perfect
figure or perfectly benevolent figure in that
i mean somewhere down the line he had to know that
this was going to be the way that this had to go
um and yeah they're really really great i think
at using these longer episodes to give you really
wonderful character pieces because yeah with
hopra it struck me literally i was like we haven't
really delved into his history as a character
aside from the stuff with sarah that we've gotten
a microscope on and just to get that monologue
he's a cop in new york too i think at some point
yeah but but that whole thing about agent orange
and and you know going overseas and and and
you know all that nastiness because yeah it's
like that agent orange is like such a horrific
and such a sort of black mark on our history
and it's something that affected so many people
in such a horrific way and yeah like to really
kind of uh inc nothing's that bad yeah you know
monsanto is still around making chemicals that we
use every day so really it can't have been that
but uh yeah like like getting those
little try getting a reaction up on time
yeah but uh i thought that in you know what what
could have and i guess cynically if you don't like
it you could call it an info dump but it's it is
like a a really rich monologue that did remind
me like we've been calling out these references
but it reminded me something more like a hill
house side of netflix where it's like yeah you're
just getting this performance and for as much as
hop's story has been so physical i really loved
that really emotional and all that played really
close up in his face and using that as also a way
to kind of bridge something of a gap between him
and enzo uh and it makes me all the more uh
worried for when he returns because you know
vectors obviously the whole thing is preying on
people's unr uh resolved traumas and like hopper
is just all under solved trauma yeah but you know
like they they find that's what they mean they
find hope within each other this group of people
and they all inevitably come together in the end
yeah and maybe that'll just like blow vechna's
battery entirely way too much trauma guys the
way they the way they're tying stuff back in so
much to all these other seasons it's like you got
the doctor from season one and the doctor from
season two now teaming up together yeah the dcu
yeah dr cinematic universe they're good at making
it feel all encompassing while also not making it
what's this door hi hi babes
shut the door yeah yeah they're good at making
it feel all-encompassing without uh well when
and and having that feel like a natural part of
the unfolding story and having it feel like just
a natural world populated by these characters
instead of it being like ah remember yeah yeah
yeah it's like i don't even remember sarah
being brought up at all in season three
um oh yeah because you got all that stuff with
them trying to build this you know surrogate
father-daughter relationship there and then i i
got it sorry so you can see no yeah it just made
i think here was a very natural place to kind of
have that all collected then because you know that
whole thing about like i needed them you know i
needed joyce and i needed jane 11. yeah you know
what there's if there's one thing that i i'm
a tad as i root for hopper and joyce a lot um
if there is one thing i'm a tad
let down by this show on is um
winona ryder specifically because especially
revisiting the show i totally forgot like
when nope a writer was like the main character in
the first season and she was just so richly ridden
and she's still great in season two uh but
like season one like she was you know she
was the only one who never gave up on will like
a lot of people were like doubting and stuff but
she always believed and she was looked at as
the crazy one but she wasn't crazy she finally
vindicated it yeah it was great and it seems like
since season three they're like let's let's make
her paired up with the another a guy making like
funny stuff yeah make a character significantly
lighter let's make her more bubbly yeah which
is fun to watch but yeah i feel like maybe one
aspect of the season that doesn't benefit certain
characters at least is the idea it's funny because
i just saw a quote by millie bobby brown and
the guy who plays will talking about how there
are so many characters and they're like you
should start killing some of these people more
because while i you know certainly don't want any
characters that we love to exit it is the sort of
thing where yeah characters who were introduced
later for for a large part seem to be having
more of the emotional uh you know zoomings in
and extrapolations which makes sense because
we've spent more time with certain characters
however it does seem like there is then a sort
of sliding of you know joyce is more of just an
active character for the plot rather than having
an emotional journey beyond just like we gotta get
hopper back and this is kind of a madcap adventure
um and i don't dislike watching it's
very similar to season three with her too
yeah exactly and so it's one of those things where
it's like i recognize you don't have all the time
and joyce and murray is a bubbly fun duo but at
the same time yeah she doesn't feel like as much
of a character in certain other like even steve
like i love steve but it seems like steve's whole
thing this season is to stand around and and
either say what we would say yeah or you know
be in in kind of every now and again he'll have
this like little friction with dustin and you
know then we move on and it's like i'm happy to
have you but i want something for your character
i mean there's still if i'm not mistaken the last
episode's like an hour and a half maybe longer
actually i think it's like an hour 40 something
something like that it's really long and then
the last two like the real last two and part
two comes out are two episodes but it's like
five hours so it's like it's like a ridiculous
amount of time yeah it's like back-to-back giant
movies yeah yeah yeah which is uh interesting um
so yeah those last two are massive so i imagine
there's gonna be time to really you know flesh
out it's not the final season but it's interesting
how they treat this show this this particular
season is in a lot of ways i keep feeling like
it sort of feels like this could be a final
season and then the way things are going yeah
yeah and there's going to be a season five
after part two right to wrap it all up
okay and uh yeah i mean i think like the mike
and will and jonathan and argyle yes there's
some there's there's some fun to be had there
but yeah i mean undoubtedly the the truly
interesting stuff comes with the other stories
hopper what's going on with um you know [__]
the vechna and everyone they're involved with the
vector story yeah hopper and everyone of all the
vacuums that's the truly engaging stuff everyone
kind of surrounding max and eddie yeah you know in
the in the thick of things and two i guess it's
also that you you kind of can see like they've
been pretty decent whenever we've at least for
me looking back across these episodes thus far
it going whenever i'm like i want to see more of
this or or you know what about that thing kind
of coming back into sharper focus and they tend
to answer those quandaries in the next episode
um and there is i think you can tell by looking
at some of those plot lines it's like maybe
they're spreading it's like for example it's
like the will and mike and jonathan all them
you know they're i feel like they kind of have
to take that plot and kind of spread it out
more in smaller chunks than other plots you know
so i can still see that culminating into something
that feels that by the end of the season you know
reasonably plugged in and satisfying and i think
right now maybe we're just in a position where
that plot line for everything they have in their
bible for this season probably just isn't as
substantial as the others and so it's getting
kind of pared out in you know wider chunks and you
can see that with certain characters and certain
stories that we do check in with just once or
twice an episode i feel like finn wolfhard and
winona ryder were like two like um just flat out
amazing characters in season one and they were
such a focus it was like they were such a like
there's a big ensemble usually have a cup a few
primary leads and they were like primary leads and
then it seems like after that they've slowly been
running out like genuine things to explore with
them yeah it yeah it feels like we got to a place
where their stories were completed and now we
don't really know what to do with their emotional
arcs as much i mean there is the thing with mike
and ellen and love yeah but beyond that yeah it
feels like they've they're they're done you've
got to focus on other characters oh yeah and 11
stuff is really interesting too yeah yeah yeah and
i mean the 11th stuff this episode was was really
really gripping and reminded me of you know a lot
of other different things especially night episode
four moon night episode four moon on episode
five five yeah a little sprinkle a little bit
like the black rainbow on top and
then moonlight invented that yeah
yeah thank you marvel thank you bart you changed
the game but even that like you know i know we
were going back and forth on like the de-aging
stuff and i thought that here they used it
conscientiously enough and i like that they kept
doing the splicing back and forth because it's
jarring but it also i think gives your brain less
time to focus in on the effect and nitpick it
and uh yeah the way that they make that sort of
psychological experiments like it really does
fit in not only with the horror and everything
but you know that sort of uh mk ultra government
conspiracy kind of thing that has always area 51
yeah yeah yeah yeah and that's you know something
that's always been a part of the show but i
think i especially associate with season one
because it is so kind of again like shady
government conspiracy thing and so yeah like being
back in that cold environment and having those
pangs from the past but also just the jarring
you know updates from the here and now present
i think are really visceral and really engaging
um yeah they why they made everyone meaner
to l so that way you feel less bad where
she goes and says like every mob of young
people is [__] that make you feel less bad
yeah maybe they don't deserve to maybe all these
conservative dicks they're all kind of mean
yeah but it also ties into her how she's dealing
with bullies again you know in her school life
that angela story is never going to be i hope
she goes back so it has to be the final scene
of this whole show yeah whole series season five
finale yeah goes back freaking just obliterates
well the stuff with eddie and
what's basketball player saying
jason i want to say um yeah because i was thinking
oh i mean this kid's got to die in front of him so
that way he can see that you know like that's
how chrissy died but now i'm thinking well
what if the guy's like oh my god curse real he
did you yeah kill him i'm honestly thinking they
might go there now it's either that or they're
going to be an unlikely duo and i think each is
as likely as the other because i mean yeah
i almost i've i've learned especially from
anime and two-part doctor who episodes
that if anything looks too optimistic
at the end of one it will be non-optimistic
at the beginning of the other or vice versa
so in that moment i was like maybe he will believe
but then also i think they could go for a nice
little subversion there or something why do none
of you talk about what's happening i know guys
come on open up is it because back then you
know like talking about the things we get
thrown in the loony bit that's right
that's right well hey i mean you know
apparently it's only still a select few of people
who know all the things that happen in hawkins
so they would be just locked up like man yeah they
would all just become creels at that point i guess
but yeah this was uh still good i still i still
would not want them written out you know like
mike and will and all that um no because every
time they do something with their character
all their like little bonding moments i'm like
yeah more well i think the i think the plot of
what that's going on is more interesting
than the character stuff sometimes to me
which is uh kind of sad because it's got to
go it's kind of kind of be like equal you know
it's going to do like the character stuff and the
plot of what whoever we're with that has to be
just as engaging uh i feel like this
depends yeah i feel like they spend
what brooch is on equal time investing in both
especially because these episodes are longer
but i feel like they don't do as much to spread
the emotional beats as judiciously so it's like
you get some really satisfying ones with certain
characters and then you get other ones that are a
little bit more just like yeah this is kind
of basic they're just kind of mending their
friendship i guess yeah you know well what i think
is neat is that if you watch stranger things as a
like a complete package i feel like the the most
constant lead has been 11 out of 11 and hopper
have been have been the most consistent strong
leads like as a leading character then and uh
if you watch all the stranger things as
a package what i think is cool is like
sometimes other people are not that lead and
now those leads are there to support these
other characters who are now going to take the
spotlight yeah yeah like max is especially max's
got a lot of attention in season two but it's
here especially she's like oh you're you're more
you're more uplifted here yeah you know
you you your circumstances tie you more
directly into the main part of what's going on
yeah exactly yeah whereas like the season two
is like you're the new girl you're mad max
and you got a you mean brother is abusive
it's really tied to the weird parts of stranger
things but it's when you're here yeah and i like
you yeah and then now uh very significantly like
her she her association with all this it's it so i
think that's a cool part of it is even though i'll
find myself craving more i'm like but at least you
know season one had they were it was these guys
season two was these guys season three it was then
where levin and hopper seem to be like the most
consistent in terms of giving them something truly
juicy to sink their teeth into yeah you know i
feel like you can always extrapolate on those two
to the degree yeah and they are like the heart
too um lost the daughter that's the father
come together to meet in the middle yeah and just
see somebody goes together all right guys well
thanks for being here you know when i last thought
when hopper did have that speech it did make me
i missed david harper's voice i know i forgot
about it i know ripping voice that david harper
has said yeah and when he's just staring off from
the distance and telling his story like yeah i was
like i'll do like a mike flanagan just a hopper
monologues episode because also too i mean what
they wrote for him was great like that flashback
i felt like we learned so much more about this guy
than we have been so long yeah yeah all righty
well thanks for being able to talk soon guys
the ogre man dude i am so glad you pledged towards
the end of the month because i myself consider me
to be an ogre man as well let's face it us ogre
men we are delicious oh yeah we are a rare breed
some people go ooh ogre gross you're like onion
yeah you smell bad yeah i understand the reference
shrek yeah yeah max schreck from the batman
returns i get where you're getting it i get the
references man yeah so ogre man i want you to know
that dude if you're feeling like being an ogre
means you have to hide yourself from the world
don't because you know what times are changing
dad bods are in when did that become a thing now
you can be out of shape a little bit and be hot
the next stage is being an ogre now yeah so dude
your time awaits you there's just going to be
so many oh graces which i believe is the female
term for are gonna be coming after you now lunging
themselves seeking their ogre teeth those green
yellow stained things into your neck it's gonna
be delicious it's raining ogre so ogre man you are
indeed a super sexy reject and don't you forget it
i want the record to show that your name on our
patreon is ogre man so i don't know who you really
are but i've been in this situation before and
i have no idea what you look like who you really
are you look like a pixie i'm just going off
of your name and i hope you know that i'm just
joking here you could be the least like an ogre
out of anybody's reals it's possible but if you
truly suffer with some kind of you know
insecurity about your physical appearance
know that none of what i said was rooted in that
because i simply have nothing to go off of nope
let the record show that is the case
not even a profile pic send us a profile
so what i'll say is thank you for being here and
i hope to god you have a sense of humor because if
you're gonna be an ogre in this world you're gonna
have to be funny in order to get some people to
like you because you're basically your looks
are not going to do you justice it's going
to drive everyone away from you unless you can
learn how to be funny go to comedy school take
an improv class write a stand-up set see you soon
thanks for being here go to your first shout out